a doe up this livelihood depends on
livestock but there is a drought
after four failed rainy Seasons millions
in arid areas have little to eat and
their animals are dying in a few days
voters will head to the polls Abdi and
his neighbors say they are more focused
on staying alive than casting their
ballots
politicians have come to look for votes
they have not told us how they will
resolve our problems they just want
votes
livestock worth millions of dollars have
died since October last year
conflict over resources boundaries and
banditry are not making things easier
many harders have left their homes to
look for food and water they have gone
to other areas to try and save their
animals but it also means thousands of
them may not be able to vote
politicians will wrap their campaigns on
Saturday they are promising better
living conditions there are parts of
this country where you know nobody wants
to know about it and then you know about
what goes on in that part of the and
unfortunately the county governments
have also not been very useful because
the county governments have resources to
provide
uh assistance to Drought victims what
has happened is that this County
governments have not allocated enough
money to livestock
Fuller said activities
this community Elders say their issues
have not been prioritized I born here
my children are schooling here
I don't have a job
my income generation is livestock
Way High School
my daily food is coming from the
livestock
you see
my livestock all has gone
my grandfather has died
huh
my children all they have got
so example I'm asking you
even my generation income is livestock
and it has gone
why do I vote
those vying for political positions in
this region have talked about ambitious
plans to reduce poverty
but many people here say they want less
talk and more action Catherine soy Al
Jazeera garissa County